[Musique]
je suis ce qu'il est convenu d'appeler
un beau parleur
enfin beau je suis peut-être pas le
mieux placé pour le dire et je vous
laisse en juger mais par leur part leur
ca oui assurément
je suis un frazer prolixe un discours
heures inlassable un bavard impénitent
j'aime parler j'aurais voulu être un
scalde scandinave un bar 200 un griot
africain 1 colporteurs d'histoires et de
légendes
je suis simplement nicolas gouget de
l'andrh fonctionnaires des finances
publiques beatlemaniaque est ainsi nos
fils comédiens non professionnels à ses
heures prêtant sa voix ici ou là j'aime
parler j'aime raconter peut-être
d'ailleurs pour certains d'entre vous
suis-je déjà une voix
peut-être avez-vous déjà entendu
illustrait les comptes de nuit de
sologne où les spectacles de lumières et
sons d'autrefois à olivet j'aime les
mots
les aime comme on aime un bon voir avec
gourmandise avec délectation
j'aime les rouler en bouche les goûters
ou palais les sentir sous ma langue
mais ce que j'aime surtout c'est quand
ils prennent corps quand ils prennent
sens car voyez-vous les mots ont un sens
et s'accorder sur le sens des mots
permet les échanges et le partage
au rebours comme disait camus mal nommé
un objet c'est ajouter au malheur de ce
monde
et si je suis ici devant vous
aujourd'hui avec un immense plaisir
c'est pour vous faire partager mon
sentiment sur des dérives des inédits
des inexactitudes des déviances qui
viennent changer le sens des mots qui
viennent modifier le sens d'une
expression et qui arrive peut-être
parfois jusqu'à pervertir un message
alors je vous prie par avance de bien
vouloir excuser ce qui pourrait vous
semblez être un inventaire à la prévert
et je vous remercie par avance de votre
patience
mais commençons si vous voulez par les
mots le mot naguère le mot naguère
signifie récemment il n'y a guère
très honnêtement combien
d'entre vous ici penser que naguère
signifiait jadis où autrefois
et oui eh bah non naguère signifierait
savoure et lorsque verlaine dans son
recueil de poèmes jadis et naguère
intitule ainsi c'est bien pour mettre en
opposition
ces deux termes jadis autrefois et
naguère récemment puisque ce recueil de
poèmes contenait des poésies qu'il avait
écrit à longtemps et d'autres qui
étaient beaucoup plus récentes
il en va de même d'ailleurs pour entend
les fameuses neiges d'antan en temps
c'est à nu santé en latin l'année
dernière et donc françois villon nous
explique que le souvenir
les dames du temps jadis s'estompe aussi
inexorablement que disparaissent les
neiges de l'année dernière il est 16
heures 02 mesdames et messieurs vous
écoutez france culture
non je passerai très rapidement sur
cette horrible pléonasme qui est au jour
d'aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui est
déjà en soi un pléonasme
continuons dans la culture le i2
aujourd'hui vient du latin hodie qui
signifie le jour présent aujourd'hui
signifie déjà au jour de ce jour au jour
d'aujourd'hui c'est ton jour du jour de
ce jour
mais demain est un autre jour ce qui là
aussi est une tautologie
enfin bon mais cela dit on pourrait
gloser aussi longtemps sur d'autres
pléonasme du type une panacée
universelle prévoir à l'avancé le tri
sélectif
j'en passe et des meilleurs mais
mais me direz-vous mais il est normal
que la langue évolue que pour qu'on
avance un peu oui d'accord mais
peut-être pas en changeant la
signification des mots
alors parfois d'ailleurs l'académie
résiste j'en veux pour preuve achalandé
achalandé signifie qui a beaucoup de
clients un magasin bien achalandé n'est
pas un magasin qui regorge de
marchandises
c'est un magasin qui a beaucoup de
clients et on retrouve d'ailleurs ce
terme dans la notion de zone de
chalandise bien connue des des
économistes ou des gens qui font des
études de marché et qui détermine une
zone de chalandise c'est à dire combien
peuvent-ils espérer avoir de clients
dans une zone géographique donnée et
c'est grâce à cette étude de zone de
chalandise d'ailleurs que la métropole
d'orléans s'est hissé au rang des
métropoles modernes puisque elle a
accueilli naguère un grand marchand de
meubles suédois et plus récemment encore
un vendeur de café hôtel
en revanche il arrive que l'académie
cède
j'en veux pour preuve des cimes et
décimé à l'origine vient là record du
latin c'est la décimation cette coutume
barbare qui consiste à exécuter après
tirage au sort
un soldat sur dix dans une légion qui
s'était mal comporté au combat un sur
dix
aujourd'hui l'académie admet que cela
puisse signifier exterminés en grand
nombre mais quand on entend un village
entier a été décimée par la grippe
on est quand même bien loin vous en
conviendrez du centre originel puisque
nous sommes dans les grandes heures
faisons un petit détour bucolique dans
les coupes forestières couple air coupes
sombres une coupe sombre consiste à ne
prélever qu'un tout petit nombre
d'arbres dans une forêt pour l'essai de
l'ombre dans le sous bois
au rebours d'une coupe claire qui
consiste à faire une clairière et à
enlever un maximum d'arbres et lorsque
nos gestionnaires nous promettent des
coupes sombres dans nos budgets
on devrait plutôt s'en réjouir et les
prendre au mot
passons maintenant si vous voulez bien
aux expressions l'expression dans
lesquelles les faits semblent précédé la
cause du type maintien on a finalement
on a bien fait prendre la bastille un 14
juillet ça tombe pile poil le jour de la
fête nationale
vous allez dire que j'exagère mais pas
si sûr que ça ait goûté la terre tourne
dans le sens inverse de celui des
aiguilles d'une montre
pas vous la terre tourne dans le sens
inverse de celui des aiguilles d'une
montre pas de piquant bas depuis qu'il
ya des montres
ah oui alors avant et thouaré comment la
terre tournait pas où aller ne tournait
pas comme ça a brûlé pour ça aux autres
exemples l'aube ou à 100° alou l'eau et
bouscatel vous prendre c'est encore l'un
versé 100 degrés qui est par convention
le niveau de températures auxquelles
l'eau auquel lockit son état liquide
pour passer à l'état gazeux
comme ce héros et le niveau auquel
lockheed son état liquide pour passer à
l'état solide
enfin l'eau se dit jamais tiens il fait
95 il serait temps que je me mette à
frémir en approche les 100 degrés non
tout ça est très drôle mais si on va un
petit peu plus loin je voudrais appeler
votre attention sur quelques
associations un peu particulière qui l'a
peuvent donner à réfléchir
des associations d'un mot et d'un
adjectif qui peuvent avoir des des
conséquences des résonances assez
particulière j'ai entendu en début
d'année à l'occasion d'un fait divers
tout à fait horrible d'ailleurs une
responsable politique fustigé ce qu'elle
appelait lice le l'antisémitisme
islamistes il faut combattre
l'antisémitisme islamistes pourquoi
islamistes
est-ce que combattre l'antisémitisme
tout seul ça ne suffirait pas il y
aurait-il plusieurs sortes
d'antisémitisme dont certains seraient
plus acceptable que d'autres il y aurait
il des antisémitisme qui mériterait que
l'on ne l'y fustigea point antisémitisme
paysans vegan protestataires s'est pas
vous imaginer l'antisémitisme cacher non
mais là où c'est un peu délicat c'est
que lorsque l'on entend combattre
l'antisémitisme islamistes
quel est le sous texte
que faut-il véritablement combattre
je vous laisse vous faire votre opinion
sur ce point autre exemple dont on nous
a rebattu les oreilles encore et encore
pendant toutes les campagnes électorales
qui se sont succédé et dont on va encore
vraisemblablement nous rebattre les
oreilles encore et encore pendant les
campagnes à venir
c'est la notion de valeurs républicaines
les valeurs républicaines
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une valeur
républicaine pose la question
a priori c'est une valeur que l'on ne
peut pas partager avec les anglais pour
cela dit on partage plus rien avec eux
donc c'est pas non plus complètement
traite enfin si grave que ça mais en
revanche on peut pas partager non plus
avec les espagnols les belges les
suédois les danois qui ont tous des
régimes monarchiques qui par conséquent
ne peuvent pas avoir de valeurs
républicaines en revanche on pourrait
avoir ce partage de valeurs
républicaines avec la russie la corée du
nord la chine populaire qui sont des
républiques et qui ont donc des valeurs
républicaines
alors qu'est ce qu'on met dans valeurs
républicaines liberté égalité fraternité
oui ce sont les symboles de notre
république mais les pays
si tu es tout à l'heure l'angleterre le
mauvais partage ses idées de valeurs de
liberté d'égalité de fraternité
ce ne sont pas des républiques donc ces
valeurs là ne sont pas intrinsèquement
des valeurs républicaines
la laïcité outre que c'est une
spécificité bien française
je vous rappellerai qu'il existe une
république islamique d'iran donc
religieuse donc non laïque
ce qui fait que à la laïcité n'est pas
non plus en soi une valeur républicaine
on est loin la de nayer et deux au jour
d'aujourd'hui l'un mais vous voyez entre
les expressions qui peuvent vouloir dire
le contraire de ce qu'elle prétende
exprimer et d expression tellement vide
de sens qu'elle arrive à dire tout et
n'importe quoi on peut véritablement
mesurer le pouvoir des mots alors si mal
nommée un objet c'est ajouter au malheur
de ce monde détournait le sens des mots
peut être bien pire encore
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]